merci Dominique un rapport qui frappe
les esprits sur les enfants en situation
de pauvreté premier constat il serait 1
million en France la pauvreté continue à
augmenter malgré la hausse générale du
niveau de vie la nouveauté de ce rapport
c'est qu'il place la valeur du travail
au cœur de ces propositions en insistant
sur le fait que bien souvent les
familles les plus démunies n'ont pas
forcément intérêt financièrement à
retrouver un emploi Anne
guerri pour les spécialistes le constat
est alarmant la France compte 1 million
de travailleurs pour plus 1 million de
bénéficiaires du RMI afin d'endiguer
cette précarité une mesure phare la
création d'un revenu de solidarité
active le RSA c'est un ensemble de
prestations sociales qui seront
compatibles avec les revenus d'un
travail car le paradoxe aujourd'hui
c'est que le bénéficiaire du RMI perd de
l'argent dès lors qu'il retrouve un
emploi puisqu'il perd aussi ses
avantages sociaux on dit que l'un des
préalables c'est de faire en sorte que
toute reprise de travail quelle que soit
sa situation de départ qu'on est passé
un jour au chômage ou 2 ans au RMI ça
rapporte forcément qu'on vous enlève pas
plus de prestations que ce que vous
allez gagner par le travail concrètement
une personne qui retrouve du travail
pourra conserver ses aides sociales à
condition que son salaire n'atteigne pas
une fois et demi le SMIC ce projet ne
peut aboutir que si on lui loue un gros
budget entre 2 et 8 milliards d'euros
dans le rapport 14 autres mesures en
matière de logement de santé et d'école
avec à la clé une obligation de résultat
et pour se faire une évaluation chaque
année car il est un autre chiffre qui
donne le vertige il existe 1 million
d'enfants pauvres et cette pauvreté- làà
dit le rapport il faudra l'éadiquer en
15 ans